[موسيقى]
انا اسمي عمر
ثالث متوسط حاليا ومن السعوديه تحديدا جده
واحب اني اروح يعني المدرسه الثانيه
واكتشفها اولا انا كنت رايحه العلا
وكنت رايح طبيعي يعني مع حالتي
زياره للمكان
فلما رحت هناك عند الجبل في الخاصه خطرت
على بالي انا ووالد انه ليش ما نشوف اراء
السياح بما انهم كسروا
وهذا الحمد لله يعني
لو قدروا يسالون على الناس جون هنا
فجات على بالي الفكره عشان الناس تعرف
وممكن اغير نظره بعض الناس
ليست يوكيم
هيلعلا
والجنسيات يعني اللي سويت معاهم المقابلات
كانوا اثنين من هولندا وواحد كان من
اكثر شيء يعني
عجبهم هنا العلا
انه الصحراء عجبتهم وكمان يعني انه راحوا
اماكن كثير برا السعوديه
شافوها وراحوا لها يعني قاموا فيها ولكن
يعني نمبر 1 او رقم واحد كان
بصراحه انا كنت مستحي شويه اني سوى
المقابلات ولكن يعني الوالد
وتشجعت وسويت معاهم اول مره اروح الجبل
فيل منطقه جبل الفيل ورحت كمان البرد
القديمه
وشفت العلا والمزارع العلا والجبال ثاني
مره كانت
دعوه من وزير السياحه مع الوزير احمد
الخطيب
[موسيقى]
ردود فعل الناس على مقاطع اللي
جريتها ونزلتها على تويتر صراحه
كثير واعطوني دعم
وطبعا وزير السياحه كمان نشاف المقطع
وحفزني واعطاني كلام وبرضو الناس يعني
يدفعوني دفع معنويه اني اكمل
واسوي العمالات
اتمنى ان يكون سفير للسعوديه طبعا